it's great to Welcome to the program
today Oren etcioni who's the founding
CEO of the Allen Institute for
artificial intelligence I really
appreciate your time today thank you
it's my pleasure good always good to
talk to humans yeah exactly right so I
mean okay let's for for some in our
audience who maybe have a general sense
of the idea of artificial intelligence
the term machine learning which I know
you have a you have a particular opinion
about and the these sorts of issues I
think they may have a general awareness
that there are people who are very
scared about the potential of an
artificial general intelligence and
there are others who have a very
optimistic view of those same
possibilities as maybe bringing Homo
sapiens to a new level of learning and
capabilities and medical advancements
Etc can you kind of lay out the the goal
posts or the guideposts as a term may be
of the perspectives on this issue those
who are pessimistic versus optimistic
what is the Crux of this disagreement
well the way I think about it is that
the computer is a pencil okay it's a
very big pencil it's a very
sophisticated tool is what I'm trying to
say and as with any powerful tool it can
be used for good uh or for bad so there
are people who worry about its impact on
jobs uh losing jobs on privacy losing
privacy uh the bias that it potentially
can exhibit in its algorithms so that's
on the one side and then there are
people who can see its potential for
discovering vaccines like the the covet
vaccine AI helped there and see that
benefit there's also a group of people
who really don't think of it as a tool
they think that somehow this uh pencil
is going to escape and become a death
star and I uh a little bit mocking of
that point of view because uh I think
that it really is just a tool that's
super interesting because it's we'll get
to the why AI might be an exception but
in Neil postman's book technopoly which
I think is from the early 90s he has a
very similar perspective in general
about new technologies which is there's
sometimes this idea of new technology
comes forward some people theorize or
speculate about possible negative
consequences the next step is well let's
figure out a way to get the positive but
not the negative and his view is that
all the positive and negative will all
exist it's a question of implementation
regulation planning and management
essentially that you can't only have the
good without the bad where some say AI
is different
is at least the theoretical ability of
an artificial general intelligence to
learn more quickly more rapidly in a way
that gets it Beyond whatever it's sort
of initial I don't even know if
programming is the right term you'll
tell me if that's even the right word to
use and so it's sort of outside of you
know social media social media is
created it exists within certain bounds
it will have good and bad and we can
regulate and manage the difference at
least in theory with artificial
intelligence would be that it can itself
go beyond the guidelines and the borders
that humans set for it does that make it
different
well let's first of all start with the
fact that there is a universal and
understandable fear about our role as
humans and technology and this goes all
the way back to the Jewish legend of the
Golem uh who is this uh robot and to
Frankenstein and so on so for centuries
we've been worried in various ways that
technology is going to have this uh
outsized role now uh it is possible it
is conceivable that one day that'll
happen so now the question is how close
or far are we from that uh apocalyptic
vision and my assessment to somebody
who's been working on this for 30 years
and who's very steeped in this
technology seeing you know the latest
thing as of just a few days ago is chat
GPT which is this program you can have
these amazing exchanges with me maybe
we'll talk about that but my assessment
is that we are still decades if not
centuries away from that Vision so
really what AI is today is a lot more
like the next generation of software so
again super powerful uh changing the
world you know your your iPhone and so
on but still very much a tool that we
can use and and the notion that it'll
somehow uh escape and become a lot more
than we expect is not really Based on
data it's based on anxiety when you look
at the data when you look at what these
computers can do they're uh amazing but
they're not autonomous right even take
the the notion of self-driving cars
autonomous vehicles other than the fact
that they're not yet ready for prime
time and effective you still tell the
car where to go right it'll keep you
safer than ever eventually but it
doesn't suddenly decide okay you know I
want to go to Cleveland
yeah and I can tell you as a Tesla
driver it's not uh exactly something to
write home about right now that the
technology which I which I know you're
aware of
um there are some who I don't know if
are actually taken seriously by folks
like you like Ray Kurzweil who for more
than a decade has been saying we're
actually now in that phase that you say
is decades or even maybe hundreds of
years away we just can't tell because
when you're in the middle of Rapid
change it just seems slower and in
retrospect we will realize it you don't
agree with that you don't believe that
that time you're describing is taking
place right now
I I not only not agree with that but
again I I caution to look at the data
right so what is uh Kurzweil who again
has an impressive uh history and
Technology what's his basis for saying
that and uh you can also look at him uh
saying a number of other amazing things
like we've reached the point where we're
going to live forever and so on I would
say that he's a very optimistic
individual Fair okay that's that that's
fair to say uh let's talk a little bit
about you mentioned the the chat
technology
um the touring test is for those who are
not familiar sort of an idea of when
does an artificial when when does an AI
type technology get good enough at
mimicking human conversation such that
an actual human like you or I wouldn't
be able to tell that we are not speaking
to another human and folks wrote in and
they said well you know you should ask
about our our Siri and Alexa like that I
think the answer is is certainly not
right is it would you agree that they
are not at that level
Syrian Alexa are are very simple but
this is something that's rapidly
changing changing so uh chat GPT which
is this new uh chatbot uh considered the
best chatbot ever it's uh reached you
know more than a million users in five
days it's freely available on the
internet uh that one is getting close to
passing the Fable Turing test is that
as big a milestone
as Decades of literature make it out to
be or is it a curiosity that is
self-contained enough that it does not
necessarily mean okay now that gets us
to some particular next level
that is a great great question and I
think the answer is that we've learned
that various
limits that we've set where we believe
gosh a computer will never do that uh
get crossed and that's in 1997 a
computer beating Gary Kasparov the world
champion in chess right uh more recently
a few years back beating the world
champion and go uh there was a recent
computer program that plays the strategy
game of diplomacy and now we have the
Turing test but each time we realize
that the computer is picking up an
aspect of intelligence but not the whole
human level thing and so particularly
about the Turing test uh New York Times
Reporter John Markov said that the
Turing test is a test of human
gullibility right so it is uh
interacting in a way that seems human
but the these programs don't really
understand what's going on
when we think about the different ways
that artificial intelligence at a level
that's slightly ahead of where it is now
but not yet at what you're describing to
be decades or hundreds of years away
when we think about some of those
possibilities there's all sorts of
different fields that we could talk
about if we talk about the medical field
and the idea of using
machine learning or whatever better term
we may have for it as well as a big data
when it comes to Patient data and
um learning an algorithm of questions
that could be answered by a potential
patient the idea of incredibly accurate
diagnosis often comes up in lots of
literature as a use for this type of
technology and that it would take out
the emotion that that is there to some
degree in a so-called real doctor and
that there's other benefits
in the field of medicine specifically is
that interesting to you is it likely or
is there something big that's missing
from those uh hypotheses that actually
makes that not a very likely uh outcome
in the next five to ten years with with
such technology
I I think this is a great example of how
powerful and beneficial computers can be
along two Dimensions first of all we can
get much better diagnoses as you
suggested based on more data and more
analyzes and secondly we can also make
it much more widely available there's so
many rural areas remote countries and
regions where the kind of medicine that
we're used to is just not available uh
and it's it's expensive to do it with
humans so if we can build programs
accessible over the Internet that can
help that's uh fantastic now I I think
that the best use of this certainly in
the foreseeable future isn't just the
computer uh taking over completely but
my favorite definition of AI is not
artificial intelligence it's augmented
intelligence so imagine that you have a
doctor with their experience with their
empathy being aided with this uh in the
fatigable assistant that reads all the
millions literally millions of papers uh
coming out that's Gathering all these
statistics and it's making
recommendations to the doctor would you
rather have your human doctor or your
human doctor with this incredible tool
at their disposal it's a no-brainer it
is I guess to play Devil's Advocate the
trend of doctors sitting there looking
at a screen rather than the patient is
already pretty bad and and if the
logistics of having the AI help have the
more sucked into the computer screen
maybe the experience won't be better but
maybe the outcome would I don't know
well again a wonderful point but I would
say this a ultimately we do care more
about the outcome particularly when it
comes to critical things but two the
reason that they're on the computer so
much is because they have all this
paperwork to fill out yes this is not a
product of AI now ai systems are coming
out right now uh that actually help to
automatically fill out the paperwork so
I think in the very near future we'll
have the computer less uh sorry we'll
have the doctor uh interesting slip
there we'll have the doctor Less on
their computer doing that and more able
to engage with with the patient I think
I think that would be that would be a
good thing last thing I want to ask you
about there all of these issues
ultimately end up being political right
stem cell research becomes political and
so does vaccines and everything becomes
political is it safe to assume and or is
it already happening that the political
lines around AI are are that those who
are more conservative in their world
view are against this type of Technology
they want to try to ban it in advance or
prevent its development and that those
who are more socially liberal or
Progressive are more open to it or is it
falling along different political lines
wow uh
I've never been asked that question so
David a wonderful question and it is
actually scrambling the political
spectrum and let me quickly illustrate
why yeah on the liberal side there's a
lot of concern about bias racism sexism
and these computer programs these AI
programs are data based and so they
sometimes absorb bias from their data so
there's a lot of concern there and on
the conservative side there's a lot of
concern about geopolitical tension and
the fact that China and others are are
attempting to become superpowers if not
uh dominant in Ai and so there's a very
strong sense that we need to invest
heavily in it uh both for economic
reasons and for National Security so
there are people all over the Spectrum
and it doesn't break out neatly we have
been speaking with Dr Oren etcioni who's
the founding CEO of the Allen Institute
for artificial intelligence super
interesting and I really appreciate your
time today and joining me
thank you so much